Russia's war in Ukraine was Unleashed
after the UK published a major review of
defense policy with the conflict still
raging a new update says this Carnage
and Chinese aggression over Taiwan risk
creating a world defined by disorder a
difficult and dangerous decade
the foreign secretary presented the
findings to Parliament across the world
State threats have grown and systematic
competition has intensified
there is a growing Prospect or further
deterioration in the coming years
it's prompted the government to announce
almost 5 billion pounds in extra money
for defense over the next two years but
most of this three billion pounds will
be invested in the UK's nuclear-armed
and nuclear-powered submarines that
leaves just 1.9 billion pounds to
replenish and grow stockpiles of
ammunition sources say it's not enough
and the Army alone needs an extra 3
billion pounds a year to avoid more cuts
the new cash will lift defense spending
to 2.25 percent of GDP by 2025 from just
over two percent now and there is a plan
to increase this to 2.5 percent but not
a time frame
publicly the ministry of Defense says
it's delighted with the new settlement
but privately the mood among some is
dire one source told me investing more
money in nuclear submarines that come
into service years from now while not
fixing the Army is an eccentric response
to a war in Europe
with a poor track record for buying kit
on budget and on time the military isn't
Without Blame we're perhaps more
more devoted to getting the best
possible system rather than the 90
solution and for a middle-sized power
with our sort of Defense budget that's
just not appropriate but the threat from
Russia is now here British troops train
Ukrainian forces on their tanks with the
UK giving its weapons away there's an
urgent need to re-arm and perhaps then
reform Deborah Haynes Sky News